luis garcia facing the royals back to
back time he's never done that before
yeah luis garcia fastball cutter slider
changes cutter and you know slider seem
like a hybrid to me he can take a little
bit off sometimes and make it more of a
slider has a little bit of a cutter
somewhere around 86 miles an hour and a
slider gets a little big to 79.
towards correa backhand play in the air
carlos correa goes down to a knee to
make sure he had that play
and maryfield lines out to start this
game
low on them to sleep with the wind up
getting the strikeouts swinging to miss
got him with the cutter a 10 pitch first
inning for luis garcia in a one two
three start to this one and now brady
singer will try to accomplish the same
thing making consecutive starts against
the astros yeah and if he does he'll do
like lynch stay on the corners the edges
quality strikes
and altuve hits one off the glove of
ryan o'hard and into right field
hit sharply but a play that normally you
would want your first baseman to make
altuve reaches to start the game
put him in the lane
slider
down goes alvarez on three pitches
that's a big out right after the walk
slider down and away will load up the
bases for carlos correa
a couple of walks here in the first
inning from singer
world ground ball right side they will
make the play to first that will score a
run now tube crosses the plate
carlos correa puts one in play with two
strikes and picks up an rbi ground out
and the astros on the board first it's
one to nothing here's a let miss diaz
on the ground lopez a diving stop and
the throw gets by the first baseman
o'hara two runs will score
o'hearn couldn't make the pick and the
astros lead three to nothing
another chance for lopez
and the inning comes to an end it was
not
a crisp
bottom of the first for the royals and
they're down 3-0
two strikeouts for garcia both have been
with the cutter which isn't a surprise
yeah
little change piece getting ryan o'hearn
luis garcia jumps off the mound with a
strikeout back-to-back strikeouts in the
inning he's retired the first six
down goes castro and that's brady's
second strikeout
and he hits a ground ball to the right
side o'hearn
gets it to singer
and that's the inning he's always ready
in case he needs to be added to the
roster in the middle of the game
taylor hits it well to left field
and that will be off
the wall
jones thought about trying to make a
play and realize it was going to be over
his head and michael will be at second
base to lead off the third inning
runners are going and the royals pull
off a double steal
taylor goes to third dyson goes to
second
so now he's busting a fastball in
got him
got him with the slider
big strikeout there for luis garcia for
the first out of the inning but good
speed
live drive caught by oled miss
showing a little vertical hop on that
jump as he left his feet to rob with
very field of a potential two rbi base
hit we got to see replay let's see how
high he gets
garcia can see his way out of this
situation he can get nikki lopez
salvador perez is on deck runner goes
here's the pitch and he's out at home
trying to steal home
and garcia delivers to castro with a
left-handed batter at the plate and they
tag them out
and a great job by
luis garcia not to panic
and deliver the ball outside away from
the left-handed batter and garcia gets
out of it with runners on second and
third and nobody out correa with an rbi
ground down his first time-up
that ball hit well to center field
taylor on the move he'll watch this one
bounce off the wall julia on the move at
third base he's gonna be waved around
he's gonna score rbi double carlos
correa it is four to nothing here's ryan
o'hearn first and third two outs
and o'hern pops one way up in the air
correa calling the outfielders off and
he camps under it and puts it away
for the final out of the inning garcia
strands two more we are through three
and a half astro leading four to nothing
that's a tough pitch to to square up it
really is his location on it has been
great and when he misses it generally he
misses it away which is what you're
supposed to do
pop up good inning for luis garcia two
ground outs and a pop-up to yuli guriel
one two three fifth we are halfway home
astros lead this game four to nothing
1-0 swinging in a miss at a slider and
it's a 1-1 count and now jim reynolds
home plate umpires walking over toward
the
astros dugout he looks like he's in some
sort of distress the trainer jeremiah
randall coming out to
to meet him may be a situation where
they're trying to convince jim reynolds
that it would be best if he did not
continue yeah i want him to take his
time at the very least yeah yeah i think
we're going to have a new home plate
umpire yep jim reynolds is coming out of
this ball game
center working the first five
for the royals
the 2-2
swinging in the mess chased the cutter
down and away and maryfield down on
strikes
fifth punch out for garcia swing and a
mess got him on the cut fastball and the
ending is over
a one two three frame for garcia he has
set down last night in a row only four
hits allowed so far by garcia
swing and a miss that's a good change up
luis garcia against ryan o'hearn
swinging for strikeout number seven two
outs in the inning dusty coming out of
the dugout with michael taylor due up
one of his finest outings of the year he
is going to get a nice hand when he
heads to the dugout 18 of 22 first pitch
strikes going into this inning
foul tip
caught by jason castro stanek picks up a
strikeout to end the inning
ground ball stannic has it to altuve for
one the turn
double play
yelling guriel continues to flash the
leather on those scoops at first
ball game over
kendall grave in a one two three ninth
a four-hit
three-pitcher combined shutout the
astros even up this series